Générique
...
-C'est une nécessité pour toutes
les nations aujourd'hui
d'avoir une place
dans l'espace.
-Ce monde est en train
de changer de façon
profonde et surtout accélérée.
Il faut orienter ces capteurs
dans les bonnes directions,
se demander quelle sera
la prochaine surprise
qui viendra de l'espace.
-Le spatial,
enjeu majeur pour une nation
et nouvelle source de tensions.
L'espace est
un terrain de conflictualité
comme à terre, en mer, dans les airs
et dans le domaine cyber.
*-6, 5, 4, 3...
-Un nouveau champ de confrontations
où les menaces se multiplient.
Conséquence, la France s'est mise
en ordre de bataille
pour conserver un avantage
stratégique et opérationnel.
Kourou, en Guyane française,
le 29 décembre 2020.
A 7000 km de la métropole,
un événement majeur se prépare.
Dans quelques heures, la France
va lancer CSO-2,
un satellite d'observation
militaire aux capacités hors normes.
Les forces armées en Guyane
sont sur le qui-vive. Leur mission,
protéger le Centre spatial français,
installé ici depuis 1968.
C'est l'opération Titan.
Une bulle de protection
renforcée est activée,
à la fois terrestre, maritime
et aérienne.
A terre, les légionnaires
du 3e régiment étranger d'infanterie
quadrillent la zone
jusque dans ses moindres recoins
avec des équipements
adaptés au terrain.
En quad et kayak, à pied
ou en véhicule chenillé.
Ou depuis cette tour de guet.
A son sommet,
un missile sol-air Mistral
pour la défense
antiaérienne.
-Source parasite, les antennes.
-Reçu pointeur.
-OK.
-En mer, une zone d'exclusion
est mise en place
par la marine nationale.
-Sécurité, sécurité, sécurité.
Ici le patrouilleur
de la marine nationale...
-Et au-dessus du Centre spatial,
le ciel aussi devient
inaccessible grâce à l'armée
de l'air et de l'espace.
-Le Centre spatial guyanais,
c'est 700 km2,
donc c'est un travail colossal.
Les forces armées en Guyane
sont chargées
de la protection externe
du Centre spatial.
L'opération Titan,
c'est à peu près aujourd'hui
250 à 300 personnes. On peut monter
jusqu'à 400 personnes
lorsque l'on a des tirs
spécifiques.
Le dispositif est mis en place
quelques jours
et quelques heures
avant les lancements,
pour neutraliser
toute la zone et faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus d'individus
ni au sol, ni en l'air,
ni dans les approches maritimes.
C'est une mission remarquable,
de par sa technologie.
En salle Jupiter,
la tour de contrôle
de la base spatiale,
la concentration est équipes
opérationnelles est à son comble.
Ce lancement est l'aboutissement
de plus de 10 ans de travail
pour les spécialistes
du spatial militaire.
Les enjeux sont importants,
le satellite CSO-2 doit être
un atout majeur pour les armées.
-La spécificité
de ce lancement aujourd'hui,
c'est que
les images qui seront
fournies par CSO-2 auront
une résolution encore meilleure
que celle offerte par CSO-1.
C'est donc une étape très importante
dans le programme MUSIS CSO
que la Direction générale
de l'armement conduit
en équipe intégrée
avec le commandement de l'Espace.
Musique électronique
...
Applaudissements
-Donc évidemment, c'est une immense
joie, une grande fierté
d'être ici aujourd'hui,
de terminer cette année 2020
qui a été pour le moins
compliquée pour tous,
par ce très, très beau succès. On a
mis en vol un satellite magnifique
qui va nous procurer des images
d'une qualité extraordinaire.
On est très impatients
de voir ces images.
Nos opérateurs militaires
sont derrière leur console,
j'imagine,
en train d'attendre ces images.
-Mais avant,
les équipes en charge du projet ont
encore du travail.
Pour le comprendre,
retour en métropole,
à Toulouse, capitale européenne
de l'industrie
spatiale. C'est ici qu'est le Centre
national d'études spatiales,
le Cnes, coarchitecte du système CSO
avec la Direction générale
de l'armement, la DGA.
Ensemble, ils ont défini
les caractéristiques principales
du satellite.
-Nous avons défini en particulier
le type de prises de vue
qui allaient être réalisées
donc dans le visible,
dans l'infrarouge,
avec une capacité couleur,
stéréoscopique.
Nous avons aussi défini
les performances associées, donc
en termes de résolution, en termes
de capacité, mais aussi
en termes de réactivité.
-Pour s'assurer
que CSO fonctionne parfaitement,
les experts du Cnes
passent revue tous ses paramètres.
Sa capacité
à prendre des images infrarouges
par exemple.
-Ces activités de mise en oeuvre
de l'infrarouge
se déroulent sur environ 3 jours.
Elles consistent à activer
le contrôle
thermique de l'instrument,
à tester les électroniques,
à refroidir les détecteurs,
afin de pouvoir prendre les
premières prises de vie infrarouge.
Maintenant que ces 1res images
infrarouges ont été acquises,
les équipes qualité
image du Cnes sont en capacité
de qualifier, régler, étalonner
l'instrument. Donc, on va qualifier
au travers
de différents profils de prises
de vue qu'on va prendre
dans les prochaines semaines,
qui vont permettre
à la fois de s'assurer
de la qualité de l'image,
de la qualité visuelle,
que ça réponde bien aux besoins
des utilisateurs, mais aussi
sa performance, notre capacité à
prendre telle ou telle prise de vue.
-CSO-2 est doté d'une fonctionnalité
nouvelle,
le contrôle d'orbite autonome.
Il est capable
de pivoter sur lui-même
pour se maintenir à poste,
une intelligence embarquée rendue
nécessaire par les conditions
d'environnement difficiles
à 480 km d'altitude.
-Cette innovation a commencé
il y a plusieurs années au Cnes.
Nous avions réalisé un démonstrateur
sur un satellite du Cnes, Demeter,
où nous avions démontré
sa faisabilité.
Cet exemple est caractéristique,
parmi tant d'autres,
sur CSO, de l'implication
des ingénieurs du Cnes
sur tout le processus d'innovation.
C'est pas que trouver
des nouvelles idées,
c'est un processus qui est complet
où ça va du besoin utilisateur,
bien comprendre,
bien évidemment aux premières idées,
à la phase de développement,
avec une phase très importante
pour le spatial, la qualification
pour le vol, l'exploitation
et bien sûr le retour d'expérience
vers les missions futures.
*-Départ en manoeuvre
pour la 1re vue terrestre
visible et infrarouge sur Brest.
-La constellation CSO est
la 1re étape d'un renouvellement
complet de la flotte
de satellites militaires.
*-Tu peux zoomer sur un visage,
s'il te plaît ?
-Pour nourrir cette ambition,
700 millions d'euros supplémentaires
sont alloués
par la loi de programmation
militaire d'ici 2025, portant
à 4,3 milliards d'euros au total
les investissements
du ministère des Armées
dans le spatial.
Pour les armées
du monde entier, les moyens
spatiaux sont indispensables
pour recueillir du renseignement,
surveiller
le terrain, communiquer et naviguer.
-Il y a toujours eu
une compétition
pour l'accès à l'espace
depuis le premier satellite
en orbite, Spoutnik 1.
Lancé par les Russes, par l'Union
soviétique et depuis cette époque,
la compétition
peut être pacifique
ou être moins pacifique
parfois en raison
des enjeux stratégiques.
D'abord, l'espace n'a pas de
frontières. Vous pouvez survoler
n'importe quel pays
à tout moment. C'est
la 1re raison pour laquelle ça a été
un sujet de préoccupation,
c'est-à-dire que vous aviez
des satellites soviétiques
qui survolaient les Etats-Unis
et vice versa.
Ca, c'est le premier avantage.
Dans le domaine militaire,
on a un adage :
qui tient le haut tient le bas.
Là, vous êtes plus haut
que tous les autres. Vous voyez
tout ce qui se passe en bas.
Ensuite, l'espace est
un fournisseur de services
sans équivalent.
Et par nature,
sur l'ensemble de la planète.
-Depuis toujours, l'espace fascine.
Pour la France,
le rêve devient réalité
en 1965. Sur la base
d'Hammaguir en Algérie,
la fusée Diamant A met sur orbite
le premier satellite
français, Astérix,
développé sous la maîtrise
d'ouvrage de la délégation
ministérielle pour l'armement.
Un succès voulu
par le général de Gaulle
et qui ouvre à la France la porte
du club fermé des puissances
spatiales,
constitué alors des Etats-Unis
et de l'URSS.
Pendant la guerre du Golfe,
entre 1990 et 1991,
la quasi-totalité du renseignement
image est apportée
par les Etats-Unis.
En 1995,
un programme d'observation spatiale
viendra donner à la France son
indépendance stratégique, Helios.
Le recours aux satellites par
les armées françaises connaît alors
une croissance ininterrompue.
-Ca vous donne
à la fois une capacité à voir,
une capacité d'élongation,
une capacité à comprendre
et une capacité à agir
qu'aucun autre domaine
ne peut fournir.
Et cela, du niveau politique
au niveau le plus bas,
au niveau tactique
pour les unités sur le terrain.
-Des capacités renforcées
par la constellation CSO.
Derrière la réalisation
de ces trois satellites,
deux industriels européens
principaux,
Airbus Defense and Space,
maître d'oeuvre des satellites,
et Thales Alenia Space, qui fournit
les instruments optiques.
Ce matin-là, à Cannes,
les équipes de Thales
Alenia Space finalisent
la mise en conteneur
de l'instrument
optique de CSO-3, le 3e satellite
de la constellation CSO
avant son transfert à Toulouse
chez Airbus Defense and Space.
-Salut, Marie.
Je voulais savoir, pour demain,
c'est toujours bon
pour la fermeture ?
-Ouais,
pour la fermeture, on est bons.
On est bons, on est dans les temps.
Hier, on a préparé l'instrument CSO
comme il fallait et là,
on est arrivés dans le sas ce matin,
on est partis sur le conteneur
ce matin, tout va bien.
-OK, super.
-On est dans les temps.
-On est très fiers
de cet instrument.
C'est assez extraordinaire
les images.
On a pu voir des images.
C'est vraiment dingue.
J'avais les poils comme ça.
C'est vraiment... waouh !
Les opticiens, ils ont vraiment
des nouvelles manières
de travailler qui font
qu'ils arrivent à la pointe.
Donc ça, oui, ça,
on s'en rend compte.
On est sur un niveau au-dessus.
-La résolution précise des
satellites CSO est confidentielle.
Dotés d'optiques dernier cri,
ils peuvent fournir
des images de meilleure résolution
et plus rapidement.
-Bonjour à toutes et à tous
pour cette 3e et dernière revue
de livraison CSO.
Le dernier modèle.
-Le 1er satellite CSO-1 est
opérationnel depuis deux ans.
Il est positionné
sur une orbite à 800 km
et contribue
à la mission Reconnaissance.
Il sera rejoint sur cette orbite
par le satellite
CSO-3 en 2022.
Le 2e satellite, CSO-2,
est dédié à la mission
Identification.
Il est placé
sur une orbite plus basse,
à 480 km, ce qui lui permet d'offrir
une résolution encore meilleure.
-Le système CSO démontre
des performances inédites
en termes de réactivité
et de qualité des images.
En particulier la précision
et la résolution
des images identification
est inédite en Europe.
-Dans le cadre de la construction
de l'Europe spatiale
de la défense, CSO est ouvert
aux partenaires européens
depuis le lancement
du 1er satellite en 2018.
-L'Allemagne,
la Suède, la Belgique et l'Italie
ont déjà rejoint la communauté CSO.
Et en échange
de l'accès de l'Allemagne,
de l'Italie à la capacité CSO,
la défense française pourra utiliser
les satellites radars
de ces deux pays.
-Trois satellites, sans oublier
leurs centres de contrôle.
Le système CSO,
ce sont aussi des stations au sol
qui permettent de commander
et de recevoir des images.
L'imagerie spatiale constitue
un des piliers du renseignement
d'intérêt militaire.
Elle permet d'observer
des zones inaccessibles
aux avions ou aux drones.
Des yeux indispensables
pour les militaires
déployés sur le terrain
et la veille stratégique mondiale.
La Direction du renseignement
militaire, la DRM,
utilisateur principal du système,
a le contrôle
opérationnel de CSO.
-Il faut
évidemment distinguer
la fourniture de l'image
et celle d'un renseignement.
Le rôle de la Direction
du renseignement militaire,
outre de livrer une image,
notre plus-value est
de la valoriser
et donc d'en extraire
l'information essentielle.
Vu du ciel, si on n'est pas
spécialiste, on peut pas faire
grand-chose d'une image.
C'est notre rôle de prérenseigner
ce que nous voyons pour répondre
à la question que nous a posée
le demandeur. Il a évidemment
une question en tête.
-Chaque jour, à Creil,
dans le Val-d'Oise,
les équipes du centre de formation
et d'interprétation interarmées
de l'imagerie produisent
et fournissent
du renseignement à partir
de l'imagerie spatiale.
-Un avion a été touché
et il a entièrement été détruit.
Hormis la queue.
-Il faut faire un BR rapide
qui passe les étages.
-Oui.
Dans le monde de l'imagerie et de la
reconnaissance, on a un triptyque.
Détecter, reconnaître, identifier.
Détecter,
c'est répondre à la question,
est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose à un endroit X ou Y ?
Oui, a priori,
il y a un véhicule, quelque chose.
Reconnaître, il y a
quelque chose
et c'est un char de combat.
Identifier, je sais quel est
le type de char de combat
ou d'avion ou de navire, etc.
Avec CSO,
mes spécialistes vont
être de plus en plus
affirmatifs dans l'analyse
des scènes qu'ils auront à décrire
et à analyser.
-Pour les experts, la nouvelle
génération de satellites
militaires CSO
constitue une avancée majeure
dans l'analyse des images.
Notamment du fait
de ses capacités infrarouges,
qui lui permettent de traquer
la signature thermique
des sites observés.
-Un exemple, des avions
alignés sur un parking
en plein soleil en journée,
je sais dire sur une photo optique,
oui, il y en a 10, mais si à côté,
je regarde l'imagerie
infrarouge, je peux
peut-être dire que c'est bizarre
parce que des ombres au sol
m'indiquent qu'il y avait
d'autres avions,
en fait, il y en avait 15.
Ce genre de choses. Ca peut
être d'autres exemples,
sur des sites
dits industriels,
avec des infrastructures,
de la tuyauterie, des cuves, etc.
En fonction de ce qu'il va
y avoir dedans, plein, vide,
la signature en infrarouge
sera différente.
Et moi, dans l'analyse
faite par mes spécialistes,
les conclusions différeront.
-Autre apport de CSO,
le nombre d'images mises
à disposition des experts
du renseignement.
Par rapport à Helios,
c'est plusieurs centaines d'images
accessibles chaque jour
contre quelques dizaines auparavant.
-Ce qui m'importe
dans ce flux d'images,
c'est de mettre l'effort
sur les bonnes priorités.
Concrètement,
ce qu'on est en train
de vivre, cette transformation,
cette révolution,
à mon sens, c'en est une,
c'est de passer
d'une phase d'observation
à quasiment
une phase de surveillance.
-Face à un tel volume de données,
les technologies
d'intelligence artificielle
vont jouer un rôle important
dans les années à venir.
Une plateforme appelée TAIIA est
en cours d'expérimentation à la DRM.
Son rôle, traiter les images
issues des satellites CSO
et détecter automatiquement
la présence d'objets d'intérêt.
-TAIIA
par lui-même va
détecter les anomalies
ou l'activité anormale.
Ca va nous faire sortir des alertes
qu'on peut regarder par nous-mêmes
et on peut avoir un indice
sur quel site est nouvellement actif
ou anormalement plus actif,
quelque chose comme ça.
On va être sur une image de 2019.
En l'occurrence, on peut voir
les différentes sous-zones
créées sous le site, ça va être
tous les quais, les bassins,
et en fonction, on aura différents
navires, en l'occurrence là,
qui vont être détectés par TAIIA.
On a du navire de guerre,
du navire civil,
du marchand.
Et à chaque fois qu'un nouveau
navire va être détecté,
il apparaîtra
dans ce tableau des alertes.
Et tous les points rouges,
c'est de l'activité inhabituelle.
En l'occurrence,
il y en avait un de plus que
d'habitude, zéro navire de guerre,
mais par exemple, ici, à cette date,
en 2018, on a pu en avoir trois.
Tu as des sous-marins, là.
-L'objectif ultime,
au-delà de faire ce suivi
et cette surveillance,
c'est d'arriver à l'étape suivante,
qui est d'imaginer
des scénarii, pour faire du
prédictif. C'est bien l'objectif
du renseignement, c'est pas tant
de décrire ce qui s'est passé hier,
mais d'essayer d'imaginer
et de proposer des options,
des perspectives de ce qui risque
de se passer demain.
-Un véritable bond en avant
pour le renseignement militaire.
A Paris, le Centre de Planification
et de Conduite des Opérations,
le CPCO,
compte depuis 2019 un bureau
dédié au spatial, sa fonction,
intégrer la dimension
spatiale à tous les niveaux,
dès le stade
de la planification des opérations.
-Le CPCO
fait des stratégies opérationnelles
sur les zones géographiques.
Le but est d'apporter l'espace
dans tous ces sujets,
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant,
de faire également
une stratégie spécifique
pour l'espace, pour encore une fois
essayer d'être
dans ce processus d'anticipation
et de réflexion
et d'appropriation du sujet espace.
Il y a également de nouvelles
missions qui vont arriver.
Je citerai l'exemple de l'alerte
avancée spatiale.
-Un système qui permet
de détecter et identifier
des tirs de missile.
La France a initié les travaux
dans ce domaine
il y a une vingtaine d'années.
Un démonstrateur d'alerte avancée
a été mis en orbite en 2009
et exploité pendant deux ans.
La composante spatiale
de cette nouvelle capacité
est au coeur du programme Ares,
pour Action et Résilience spatiale.
Qu'ils soient
d'observation, d'écoute,
de communication ou de navigation,
les satellites sont
aujourd'hui incontournables.
Mais ils sont aussi vulnérables
face aux menaces.
-Il y a des nations
qui poussent la compétition,
je dirais, un peu plus loin
et ce qu'on observe,
c'est que l'espace devient
un domaine de confrontation.
De confrontation possible
entre des puissances militaires.
Il y a des menaces de nature cyber,
il y a des menaces
beaucoup plus physiques,
mais qui restent non destructives
ou avec des effets en tout cas
qui sont non permanents.
Vous pouvez avoir de
l'éblouissement, du brouillage,
vous avez des menaces
non intrusives, de l'espionnage.
Et dernière extrémité du spectre,
vous avez des menaces
destructrices ou destructives
avec des effets qui
peuvent être permanents.
Les moyens les plus spectaculaires
qu'on a pu observer,
ce sont
les missiles antisatellites,
qui ont été tirés,
en tout cas les essais
qui ont été faits
par trois nations depuis 2007
et qui ont montré qu'on savait
depuis le sol tirer un missile
pour détruire
un satellite en orbite basse.
-Après les Etats-Unis,
la Russie et la Chine,
l'Inde est devenue
récemment le 4e pays
à faire la démonstration
d'une telle technologie.
Du sol, on ne voit pas tout.
Alors, comment faire face
à ces menaces venues
directement de l'espace ? En 2018,
la ministre des Armées, Florence
Parly, dévoilait une tentative
d'espionnage d'un satellite
franco-italien, Athena-Fidus,
par un satellite russe.
Maîtriser l'espace,
une ambition majeure
de la nouvelle stratégie
spatiale de défense, élaborée en
2019 et incarnée par le programme
Ares. Objectif: accroître
notre connaissance de la situation
spatiale,
protéger nos futurs satellites
depuis la terre ou l'espace,
et mener
des opérations spatiales militaires
dans le but de décourager
les actes inamicaux
dans le respect
du droit international.
La division
préparation de l'avenir
du commandement de l'espace
étudie les besoins futurs.
-La division traite des aspects
techniques des capacités spatiales
qui sont en orbite
ou qui le seront prochainement,
aux côtés de l'état-major
des armées, des armées et puis,
de la DGA. Elle traite aussi,
comme son nom l'indique,
de sujets plus prospectifs,
des besoins des armées,
de spécification
de ses futures capacités spatiales.
Nous travaillons par exemple
sur les futures constellations
d'imagerie et d'écoute spatiales
avec toutes les forces.
-Le nom de ces futurs programmes,
CERES, pour Capacité d'écoute
et de renseignement
électromagnétique,
ou encore Syracuse IV,
satellite de télécommunications,
qui seront lancés d'ici 2022.
-La division préparation de l'avenir
s'occupe
de la définition des besoins
en matière de surveillance
de l'espace,
de protection des satellites
et esquisse les contours
du futur Centre de commandement
et de contrôle
des opérations spatiales.
-Ce futur Centre des opérations
spatiales sera localisé
à Toulouse d'ici 2025,
où sera regroupé l'ensemble
de l'écosystème
du commandement de l'espace,
les unités, un laboratoire
d'innovation spatiale,
mais aussi un nouveau
centre d'excellence de l'OTAN.
L'idée, atteindre
la même maturité dans le domaine
spatial que dans les autres milieux,
terrestre, aérien et maritime.
-Appréhender une menace dans
l'espace,
c'est appréhender tout comportement
et cela, selon une temporalité
propre au domaine spatial.
Le domaine spatial représente
des durées d'opération
nettement supérieures
aux autres domaines.
C'est la maîtrise
de cette nouvelle boucle temporelle
plus complexe,
plus difficile à anticiper,
qu'il faut maîtriser pour
à terme maîtriser
les capacités spatiales
qui concourront à la défense
de nos capacités nationales.
-De nouvelles menaces,
donc de nouvelles
protections à concevoir.
A la Direction
générale de l'armement, différents
moyens de défense sont à l'étude.
-Ca peut être soit
des actions de défense intrinsèques,
c'est-à-dire
des technologies embarquées
à bord de nos satellites
pour les protéger.
On peut penser
à des dispositifs simples
de surveillance
périmétrique des abords,
que chaque satellite sache
ce qui gravite autour de lui.
Ca peut être des dispositifs
qui permettent de se rendre robustes
et on peut également parler
de dispositifs
de défense extrinsèques,
c'est-à-dire
pas directement implémentés
sur nos satellites,
mais sur des moyens déportés.
Donc là, je pense notamment
à ce concept de satellite guetteur,
des petits satellites
qui graviteraient autour d'objets
stratégiques à protéger,
pour être capables d'intervenir,
de s'interposer en cas de menace.
-Parmi eux, YODA, un satellite
patrouilleur ou guetteur,
avec une mission, veiller
sur les capteurs en orbite
géostationnaire.
-Ce que l'on veut éprouver
avec cet objet,
c'est, on sait que, demain,
pour mener des opérations
défensives dans l'espace,
il faudra certainement
maîtriser les technologies
à se mouvoir de façon très précise
et c'est l'un des objectifs premiers
de ce démonstrateur,
de valider les technologies qui vont
nous permettre de manoeuvrer
en sécurité.
-Le projet YODA préfigure
une gamme d'engins spatiaux,
que le ministère des Armées
s'apprête
à mettre dans l'espace.
Des concentrés
de technologie, qui ne seront
non plus seulement chargés
d'appuyer les opérations
sur terre, mais d'agir
depuis le ciel
et vers le milieu spatial.
La France poursuit
son odyssée de l'espace.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...